wer mit einem carsharing fahrzeug oft
schnell fährt um zeit zu sparen braucht
sich nicht zu wundern wenn ihm mit der
kündigung des vertrages gedroht wird
die vernetzten wagen wissen nämlich
ganz genau wer wann wie schnell fährt
sie zeichnen es auf und schicken die
daten der zentrale stellt deren software
dann einzupacken fahrstil fest so ist es
zumindest schon passiert wird ein
mahnschreiben verschickt willkommen in
der zukunft was auto sonst alles noch
auszeichnen wies und sogar ins
gefängnis bringen kann das jetzt in
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
am liebsten würde ich mal einen
einspieler so ein video für verstehen
sie spaß produzieren am steuer sitzt
ein prominentes opfer
man schaltet eine ampel so blöd dass er
bei rot über die ampel fahren muss
keine andere wahl hat einfach so schon
entscheiden und danach schickt ihnen das
navigationsgerät automatisch zu einer
polizeistreife
er wird ganz schön blöd aus der
wäsche gucken aber so absurd ist dieser
gedanke allerdings gar nicht denn die
modernen autos sind mit so viel
elektronik vollgestopft und zudem immer
online
da ist es ein leichtes mit
verkehrssündern umzugehen und fast ist
es schon realität geworden am markt kam
jedenfalls wegen der erfassten daten
seines 35 fahrzeugs ins gefängnis
allerdings auch gerechtfertigt mit den
daten konnte ihm nachgewiesen werden
dass er bei einem zusammenstoß viel zu
schnell mit dem geliehenen auto
unterwegs war dabei kam ein
unbeteiligter radfahrer ums leben aber
man bot musste für knapp drei jahre ins
gefängnis drivenow behauptete damals
zwar dass die daten erst für den
prozess mit denen des kunden verknüpft
worden
wer aber schon mal ein mahnschreiben von
dem carsharing dienstleister bekommen
hat der dürfte da wahrscheinlich einen
etwas anderen eindruck haben weil im
test der stiftung warentest kam jetzt
heraus dass alle getestet mit den autos
verbundenen apps für android und ios
denn nur bei den apps kann man das
überhaupt checken viel mehr und vor
allem personenbezogene daten an die
autohersteller
geschickt wurden als sie eigentlich
dürften da landeten zum beispiel die
fahrzeugidentifikationsnummer zusammen
mit dem standort des autos beim
autohersteller
es ist überhaupt nicht ersichtlich
wofür der hersteller diese
informationen braucht exakte
bewegungsprofile können damit erzielt
werden da wird dann der gläserne
bürger ausgerechnet über sein eigenes
auto ermöglicht und vor allem klärte
keiner der fahrzeughersteller vorher die
kunden umfassend und verständlich über
seine daten sammelwut auf und das muss
er aufgrund von bundesdatenschutz und
telemediengesetz machen am krassesten
war übrigens die sammelwut von tesla
achtung tesla sammelt überall und
verknüpft fleißig die daten von
öffentlichen datenbanken werkstätten
sozialen medien und marketing firmen
noch schlimmer über fernzugriff sammelt
tesla unter anderem über die
bordkameras daten zum fahrstil und
übergibt bei dienstwagen
die firma des angestellten oder auch an
behörden von sich aus rott ich bin hier
ansonsten einen riesen tesla in massen
basics und so weiter ferne
aber naja es zeigt sich auf jeden fall
hier muss besser kontrolliert werden und
den autoherstellern ganz genau auf die
finger geguckt werden
ich bin jedenfalls froh dass ich nicht
für jedes falschparken blechen muss der
welt schnell ihr wachstum halte ich
natürlich auf dem laufenden
zum thema datenschutz und wenn ihr kein
video dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
genau auf die leute hier geht es weiter
mit bakterien als datenspeicher hammer
thema also nicht verpassen und
draufklicken viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran